Brian Cox Rockstar physicist who made
space cool for many of us he is a
professor of particle physics at the
University of Manchester and has been
the host of many science shows and
documentaries including wonders of the
universe before he specialized in Making
Science easy to understand he wrote one
very long and hard to understand PhD
thesis and I've taken one for the team
and tried my best to read through this
so that you can understand some of the
work he did as a student without having
to slog through the whole thing yourself
here's the first page the thesis is
titled double the fraction dissociation
at large momentum transfer don't worry
if that means nothing to you because it
meant nothing to me last week but I
think I've got a grip on it now this was
submitted in 1998 at the University of
Manchester to earn Brian Cox the title
of doctor and allow his career to move
forwards onto more research and
professorship I learned a lot of really
interesting particle physics whilst just
trying to understand the introduction
turns out the internal structure of a
proton is way more complicated than I
knew and really this thesis is all about
trying to understand just a little bit
more about what's going on inside a
proton in physics we first learned that
in an atom there is a nucleus containing
positively charged protons and neutral
neutrons those are surrounded by
negatively charged electrons
then we might learn that protons and
neutrons are actually made up of smaller
particles called quarks but that is far
from where we should stop like charges
repel and if electromagnetism was the
only force in charge of the nucleus then
it would fall apart so what keeps the
nucleus of an atom intact there must be
some really strong force overcoming the
repulsion that each proton feels from
one another protons and neutrons both
experience the strong force but
electrons don't what protons and
neutrons have in common is that they
both contain quarks so it seems like
quarks have something to do with the
strong force and it turns out that is
the case because quarks can interact
with the particle that carries the
strong force the gluon gluons are
massless particles that jump from Quark
to Quark to mediate the strong force the
study of the strong force and how it
works is called quantum chromodynamics
because it relates to the color charge
carried by the quarks quarks also come
in the flavors up down strange charm top
bottom and the anti-quarks of each of
those such as anti-up and anti-down a
quark anti-quark pair will annihilate if
they Collide the energy could turn into
a gluon which can then reappear as
another Quark antiquark pair we could
have an up and an Ante Up combine to
form a gluon which then becomes a down
and an anti-down and that can continue
each gluon can split temporarily into a
quark anti-quark pair or even two gluons
so at any given moment the internal
structure of a proton is actually very
complicated so much so that throughout
this thesis instead of saying Quark or
gluon when referring to particles inside
a proton the word Parton is often used
instead which means any particle that
could be inside to find out about this
complicated proton structure Brian Cox
studied what happens when electrons are
fired at protons in a particle
accelerator chapter 2 of The Thesis is
all about the H1 detector at the Hera
particle accelerator in Hamburg Germany
which is where Brian performed these
experiments Hera ran from 1992 to 2007
and could Collide protons and electrons
at high energy to see the unseeable
there are three important parts of
particle physics experiments
accelerating particles smashing them
together and recording that collision
with detectors the particles in Brian's
experiments were accelerated in the hope
of knocking a quark in a proton hard
enough that nothing else matters if a
kid tried to tackle a big rugby player
even with impact the rugby player would
still have a grip on the ball but if
another rugby player tackled them
there's a much greater chance the ball
will fly out of hands the rugby player
might be a proton and the ball is a
quark in a violent high energy Collision
we could knock the Quark clear of the
proton and gain new information for
charged particles like electrons and
protons we can accelerate them using
electric Fields a proton in an electric
field will feel a force in the same
direction the field is pointing the
field might be made by two plates
attached to a battery but instead of one
long line of plates many accelerators
are a circular and work like a
playground roundabout if someone pushes
the ride every time it comes past them
it will spin faster and faster with
every push here is synchrotron worked in
a similar way using magnets to keep the
particles in a circular path with
multiple points of acceleration getting
to that top speed took a few different
stages when it comes to detection the
most common technique is to measure
ionization from electrons getting
knocked off of atoms when a charged
particle passes through matter the
electric field of the particle knocks
the negatively charged electrons from
atoms in the matter leaving positively
charged ions
an external electric field pulls the
electrons and ions even further apart so
they can't recombine the detector
collects those electrons allowing
physicists to measure the ionization at
each point away from the Collision if a
runaway car lost its brakes and entered
a cornfield each plant would slow it
down a little that's what a particle
traveling through the detector is like a
fast and heavy car would take a lot
longer to come to a stop and so would a
more energetic particle magnetic fields
also cause charged particles to move in
curved paths with low energy particles
curving more so detectors can gather
information about the path charge and
energy of a particle Chapter 3 of The
Thesis discusses more of the underlying
Theory motivating the research it's very
Advanced and mathematical he goes into
more depth about Quantum chromodynamics
and how to reconcile it with other
theories there is mention of the pomeron
a mysterious virtual particle where the
gluon carries the strong force between
quarks the pomeron is thought to carry
the strong force between protons chapter
4 shows the results of some experiments
and makes mention of observed Jets jets
are actually pretty cool and weird turns
out that quarks can't exist on their own
once they've been knocked out of the
proton this rubber band represents the
strong force connecting two quarks when
the two ends are close there is little
Force but when the ends are separated
the force increases think of the rubber
band stretching as a quark and
anti-quark moving away from each other
after a collision
as the rubber band becomes tighter its
energy increases until it snaps the same
concept applies to quarks and antiquarks
as they move apart the strong force
between them grows stronger until it
becomes too intense for the available
space to contain the energy at this
Breaking Point transforms it into a new
Quark anti-quark pair
now there are two Quark antiquark pairs
the original pair still moving apart and
the newly created one when it comes to
rubber bands the process ends at this
point but with quarks it's just the
beginning the original pair and the
newly created pair continued to move
away from each other and this process
repeats converting energy into the mass
of new particles until the adjacent
pairs are no longer moving away
bend the Quark anti-quark pairs joined
to form mesons that travel in a straight
line along the original Direction
mesons are small particles made up of
one quark and one antiquark examples
include the Pion and Kayon in this wild
process quarks and gluons have become a
jet of mesons Brian compares the energy
distributions of observed Jets to
simulations you can't draw any
statistically significant conclusions
from these first experiments because he
encountered many difficulties including
that some parts of jets fell outside the
detector he also had high uncertainties
in identifying subjects these
difficulties led him to think up a new
approach for the next chapters chapter 5
is where the name of the thesis comes
from double diffractioned Association at
large momentum transfer let's break down
the title dissociation refers to a
system of particles breaking apart into
two or more separate final States after
a collision diffraction means the
particles are scattered double means
we've got two separate systems in the
final State and large momentum transfer
written like this just means that a
large amount of momentum is transferred
from the incident particles to the
scattered ones the example studied
throughout this work is a high energy
Photon the basic unit of light
interacting with a proton and producing
two Jets call them X and Y in the final
State X is the backward jet from the
photon side and Y is the forward jet
from the proton side the new Focus here
and in chapter 6 is in measuring a
double dissociation differential
cross-section a cross-section is a
measure of the size of the interaction
area between two particles in a
collision it's like a probability that
the interaction will occur Brian
measured the probability of the doubled
Association interaction as a function of
energy and the angle of particles
relative to the beam axis to see if the
interaction is more or less likely as
the energy of the particles involved in
the Collision increases in the summary
we can see that Ryan Cox has compared
the cross-section results to a
perturbative Quantum chromodynamics
model and found that it was consistent
with a colorless object the theorized
pomeron being exchanged in the
interaction the results were not
conclusive enough to say for sure but
that finding was still one of the main
contributions of the thesis another
contribution was having measured the
doubled Association differential
cross-section in this specific energy
range for the first time in the time
since this thesis was published in 1998
particle physics has made a lot of
progress but the idea is that Brian
studied are still relevant efforts were
made to combine the Quark models
described here with the standard model
of particle physics the standard model
does not include a pomeron so with our
current understanding whilst it was a
useful mathematical object the pomeron
is not a real particle in the sense that
it is not detectable interestingly
though since modern String Theory arose
out of trying to explain the results of
scattering experiments involving
particles with two or more quarks the
mathematics of the pomeron has gained a
new use in string theory and has lived
to see another day you might associate
Ryan Cox more with the study of space
than with particles but astrophysics and
cosmology stand hand in hand with
particle physics many of the particles
studied in colliders were only present
in the universe during the earliest
moments after the big bang at that time
the universe was very hot and particles
were moving extremely quickly with a lot
of energy
thesis studied particles with high
energy and experiments like these are
recreating the conditions of the early
universe
through this we can understand how
matter came together and why the
universe contains anything at all
particle physics is a way to perform
experiments to understand the wonders of
the universe rather than relying on
observations of space alone thank you
for watching this video and thanks to my
patreon supporters for making it
possible a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day Stanley
thank you